if you're talking about the top sectors
because they're still for instance in if
you're talking about science if you're
talking about tech if you talk about
engineering these sectors there's still
a lack of women why because the women
don't go and do it if there's a lack of
women go and do it I wanted to be a bus
driver there was lack of women you know
I've done I didn't complain and say
there's no women bus drivers go and do
it they have no managers go and do it
don't sit back complaining that in these
top sectors nowadays you've got all the
qualifications you the young people you
can go University you can get degrees go
and do it you know I mean women if you
want to do something don't complain
about it change it like you said women
are doing it but the results are still
not the same not really they're not
doing nothing
women are the most educated but they
don't make more money because they have
a ton of debt and women don't make the
majority of workplace deaths where's the
equality where are the marches men are
the majority of workplace deaths they do
all of the hard jobs therefore they get
more money do you want to be a plumber
do you want to be a bricklayer